in most of the country the great wolf is
back on the endangered species list in
february a judge ruled that federal
officials acted improperly when they
took the animals off the list two years
ago but the decision does not affect the
states that border yellowstone national
park including montana where changes to
hunting rules last year gave wolf
hunters access to land on the park
boundary during last winter's hunting
season 25 of the park's 114 wolves were
killed when they wandered outside the
park now the topic is dividing the local
community including some biologists and
tourism entrepreneurs who want to see
the wolves protected and local ranchers
who say the wolves pose a major threat
to their way of life
in the foothills of the northern rockies
as we're looking off to the south that's
yellowstone park
father and son run a sixth generation
cattle ranch we've always had cattle my
dad had cattle here
way before my time
a tough business as profits shrink and
real estate soars everything is always
fighting against you
whether that's sickness in the cattle
predators noxious weeds so they run a
side hustle guiding elk and deer hunts
these days with fewer trophy bull elk to
track could you sustain your cattle
ranch if you didn't have the hunting
business as well no we couldn't and a
lot of ranchers
are finding that recreation is becoming
another avenue to
sustain the family farm
both businesses compete with wolves they
say prey on their game and livestock i
came up one morning and there was a wolf
it just killed a calf and so i
opened the window and shot the wolf
right from the tractor
wolves have been absent here for a
century until they were relocated to
yellowstone from canada 27 years ago it
was a disaster for us at least one pack
left the park and moved in nearby they
were killing between five and ten
thousand dollars worth of calves a year
and so you know with the extra stress
our cows weren't getting bread again for
the next craft crop but for the park
service their return has rebalanced an
ecosystem that had been thrown off by an
over abundance of elk and you can see
out here
this is prime elk range last summer we
spoke to biologist doug smith who led
that effort
and before the predators were returned
to yellowstone all of this was heavily
grazed those trees out there some of
them were eaten down by the elk because
we didn't have wolves cougars and bears
at the numbers they should be so this
changed how this whole plateau
functioned before the settlers arrived
as many as 500 thousand roamed the west
by the middle of the 20th century they
were wiped out now thanks to the
endangered species act the wolves are
making a comeback and now west of the
mississippi river we probably have three
thousand across
seven states
and that's not that many and where they
exist
makes those places unique it's saving
the ecosystem but it's also an economic
driver the 100 wolves that have settled
inside the national park became a
tourist draw no one had expected
bringing in at least 35 million dollars
to the local economy every year you live
in finland yeah
and you came all the way to montana
absolutely it's unique it's the only
place in the planet we can see the
wolves like that in nature interacting
with the buffaloes with the wildlife
capitalizing on the wolf sensation
nathan varley started wolf trackers
almost 20 years ago i mean you've
invested in vans scopes you have people
you employ absolutely this has become
our livelihood we get to meet very
interesting people from all over the
country all over the world i mean we
love what we do
but we need the wolves to do that
jeopardizing that montana's decision to
scrap the buffer zone on land outside
yellowstone's northern border
now as many as 10 can be shot by a
single hunter the harvest of wolves was
disproportionately focused on those
walls that live in and around
yellowstone national park 19 of
yellowstone's 114 wolves were killed by
the park boundary in montana last season
pat byworth with montana's fish and
wildlife commission says the new hunting
policy has been divisive literally the
community is severing over wolves
that's not a good policy for any agency
to create division and tear apart a
community are you concerned this could
wipe out everything you've worked for oh
yeah oh for sure i mean yellowstone is
the most famous wolf population in the
world our study is one of the most
recognized scientific studies on wolves
this is a handful of wolves that could
change
pack dynamics
and really affect visitor enjoyment the
social situation is complex with so many
competing economic interests we're the
endangered species
and when we're gone these beautiful
ranches as you're about to see
are going to be subdivided and there
ain't going to be habitat for wolves or
elk or any of the wildlife and that's
why we have to have a balance the stakes
are high for everyone as another hunting
season approaches listen to the people
who rely on those wolves either for
business or for recreation or
stock growers who protect their
livestock from predators like wolves so
we have to balance all these different
interests
and still maintain wolves on the land
and it's not just a problem in the
northwest you're seeing this in places
like wisconsin and michigan but nowhere
else in this country do you have the
competing economic interest that you
have in yellowstone or quite frankly the
opinions about wolves i've never seen
anything like it there's a true hatred
for this animal in a way that is
instilled in the history the folklore
but it it means something because they
have had a devastating impact and a love
for it too yeah but but it's it's tough
and it's interesting to hear zane talk
about himself
as an endangered species it's so
challenging to balance all these
interests it is it is but worth it right
yeah